In the next lesson, we'll be looking
in more detail at the technologies for
aggregating data from diverse EHRs.
A specific example is BioSense 2.0,
a system developed at the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention,
the CDC, here in Atlanta.
An often cited example of
the use of this technology
is the Tarrant County Public Health
Department in Fort Worth, Texas.
Which uses it to collect and analyze
data from 60 regional hospitals for
a key and foundational role
that public health plays.
Syndromic surveillance,
monitoring for disease outbreaks.
Here you see as an example a time
order display of the number of visits.
Typically these would be
emergency department visits for
a particular clinical problem.
The capability to produce this in
a timely manner across an entire region
is a powerful surveillance tool